[Musique]
la france est la terre de tous les
possibles
c'est ma conviction et la france je
laime pourquoi j'aime tant au delà dit
être né comme le dit le monde entier
pour son pour sa gastronomie
ce que j'aime aussi c'est son histoire
son architecture ses paysages manger un
paris brest face à la scène est ce que
j'aime par dessus tout c'est son
hospitalité
mes parents étaient réfugiés politiques
portugais et ont choisi la france comme
terre d'accueil au milieu des années 60
pour une vie meilleure
il n'avait pas 20 ans ils l'ont tout de
suite remarqué quel pays formidable des
valeurs fortes du travail pour tous et
des conditions de vie prometteuse ils se
sont rencontrés en france s'ils sont
mariés ils ont travaillé toute leur vie
et ils ont eu quatre merveilleux enfants
je suis allé au portugal pour la
première fois à l'âge de 5 ans le calme
était revenu et mes parents n'étaient
plus inquiété par la situation du pays
j'ai découvert le pays de mes parents
mais était ce vraiment le mien en tout
cas pendant toutes ces années j'ai
bénéficié d'une double culture qui
m'attend habité par la suite je me
souviens un jour à l'âge de 15 ans mon
père me dit mon fils j'aurais aimé être
patron le patron il crée de la richesse
pour son pays
hilton du travail et il permet aux
travailleurs de construire leurs rêves
à 40 ans mon père avait eu l'opportunité
de racheter l'entreprise dans lequel il
travaillait elle était en difficulté et
risquait de disparaître
il n'a jamais pu la racheter il ne se
sentait pas capable
l'entreprise a disparu avec les salariés
je ne serai jamais patron me disait-il
je sais que toi tu pourra l'être moi dès
l'âge de 10 ans mon rêve c'était d'être
architecte
je suis fasciné par la capacité des
hommes à construire des bâtiments aussi
immense dans mes rêves je suis spider
man je me déplace d'immeuble en immeuble
non père ne parle de temps en temps
l'entrepreneuriat comme s'il me confier
une mission
peut-être un moyen de remercier la
france pour son hospitalité
malgré des notes catastrophiques et une
conduite discutable mon père a la
conviction que je deviendra chef
d'entreprise et que j'en ai les
capacités qu'elle précieux cadeau pour
un fils d'être valorisés par son père
faut dire que je pars avec un léger
désavantage les parents ont appris à
parler français salon quelques années
avant moi il leur est difficile de
m'aider dans ma scolarité et d'avoir des
meilleures notes
les notes il décide de me faire
confiance et c'est ce qui m'aidera toute
ma vie seulement ces fameuses notes ne
permettront pas de faire des études
d'architecte
je choisis par dépit d' étudier
l'électricité dans un lycée
professionnel
les parents sont fiers de moi seulement
ils ne peuvent pas financer mes études
il me suggère de travailler le week-end
pour gagner de l'argent
alors je vend des poulets sur les
marchés à la grande surprise sans
diplôme sans expérience sans permis il
est assez simple de trouver un job plus
difficile c'est de se lever tôt très tôt
je prends goût monde du travail
et l'année suivante je me dirige vers la
voie de l'apprentissage
à l'époque on dit que les jeunes qui se
dirige vers la voie de l'apprentissage
sont des cancres et que c'est une voie
par défaut à l'époque ça c'était avant
en 1990 je signe un contrat
d'apprentissage dans une société de
câblage électrique
je suis super motivé 1990 c'est aussi
l'année de la guerre du golfe
quelques mois plus tard non patron
annonce à mes cinq collègues et moi
qu'il va devoir liquider l'entreprise à
cause de cette sacrée guerre du golfe
je l'avais surpris quelques semaines
auparavant avec le commercial dans son
bureau en train de jouer aux cartes
sacré guerre du golfe
je me rends compte à quel point il est
facile de détruire des emplois moi qui
rêvais d'en créer mission non accomplie
au fond de moi j'ai la conviction
secrète d'avoir le super pouvoir de
créer des emplois je poursuis mon
apprentissage dans une grande entreprise
capable de supporter toutes les guerres
à 1 21 ans je signe mon premier cdi dans
une pme
trois ans plus tard elle est en
difficulté une récession nous disaient
nos patrons je crois que c'est de cela
dont il parlait chaque jour pendant de
longues heures au restaurant sacré
récession l'entreprise est contrainte de
procéder au licenciement économique de 6
salariés et comme je suis délégué du
personnel je suis chargé leurs annonces
et anna leur licenciement car la
direction n'a pas le courage moi qui
rêvait de créer des emplois j'ai la
sensation d'en détruire encore raté
je suis déçu par ses premières
expériences je me sent démuni face à
cette situation je décide de
démissionner j'ai besoin de voir autre
chose d'explorer le monde de faire des
rencontres
à 25 ans je décroche un poste de
technicien itinérant bilingue je parle
très peu l'anglais voyait quelques mots
de quoi commander une bière
la première semaine je suis envoyé en
angleterre ah oui à première vue ça peut
paraître compliqué mais je me rends vite
compte qu'on mène note pas on ne juge
pas on veut juste ne comprendre quand je
dois vous dire que une des spécialités
des portugais c'est parler avec les
mains et le coeur pendant quatre ans je
découvre la france de long en large et
une partie de l'europe
jali travail et découvertes
je découvre des lieux et des personnes
surprenant je m'enrichis des expériences
des autres on
juin 2002 je parlais volet de ma maison
et je suis pris de soudaines douleurs à
l'abdomen
quelques heures plus tard les douleurs
de vienne intense et je suis transporté
d'urgence à l'hôpital
je subis une dizaine d'examens et mon
état se détériore
mes poumons se noircissent le lendemain
je suis sous assistance respiratoire
les médecins diagnostiquent une
infection généralisée des poumons
il faut que je sois opéré d'urgence à ce
moment là mon espérance de vie est de 48
heures quelques jours plus tard mon état
s'améliore
les douleurs sont toujours intenses mais
je respire je dois rester en soins
quelques semaines à l'hôpital dont le
service pneumologie je suis entourée
d'hommes pour la plupart atteints du
cancer du poumon causé par la cigarette
michel mon voisin de chambre ne fait
part de ce héros morts je rêvais de
créer une entreprise et maintenant c'est
trop tard
pourquoi je les passais avant qu'est ce
que je vais faire de ma vie
son témoignage nous rappelle ma mission
d'entrepreneuriat mon rêve de grands
bâtiments et c'est dans mon lit
d'hôpital que je commence à créer mon
projet d'entreprise en réalité j'avais
qu'une idée en tête des branchés mais
sonde me lever et fils est dans un bon
restaurant
et c'est ainsi que me vint l'idée de
créer un guide gastronomique le passe à
table n'est c'est ma première expérience
de dirigeant et elle est compliquée
malgré mon énergie est la conviction que
j'ai arrivé je me rends compte que
j'avance difficile mais difficilement
fait je pense pas du tout je me rends
compte que je ne suis pas prêt après
deux ans d'activité
je décide de stopper l'entreprise est de
redevenir salarié en 2008 j'ai
l'opportunité de racheter une entreprise
de travaux sur cordes
tels des spiderman ses salariés
nettoient les vitres des grands
bâtiments
l'entreprise existe depuis 15 ans elle a
trois salariés elle est en difficulté
nous sommes en 2008 en pleine période de
crise
mais cette fois ci c'est moi qui suis
aux commandes
je décide de ne pas être victimes et de
ne pas devoir annoncer au salarié que
c'est la crise qui est responsable de la
perte de leur emploi
en tout cas je me promets de ne pas
jouer aux cartes
c'est malgré tout un vrai coup de poker
car l'activité de l'entreprise est très
faible il faut la développer
c'est par cela que j'ai commencé je me
souviens des premiers jours je pars chez
un prospect avec le véhicule de société
ce contrat important permettrait de
payer les salaires
en chemin je me fais arrêter par deux
gendarmes
1 et 2 et fortement usées et je dois le
changer sur place immédiatement par la
roue de secours
après vérification la roue de secours
est crevé
ils poursuivent le contrôles et
détectent un défaut de carte grise
d'assurance de contrôle technique
ils me demandent vous avez au moins
votre gilet jaune
pas de gilet jaune malgré mes
explications
il mime ordonne d'aller chez le premier
garagiste pour changer mes pneus
j'aimerais aujourd'hui m'excuser
publiquement auprès de ces deux genres
drame je suis pas allé chez le garagiste
j'ai préféré honorer mon rendez vous le
contrat a été signé et les salaires
versés alors que le contrat le pardon
alors que le statut auto entrepreneur
fait son apparition
l'entreprise fait face à une concurrence
forte
nous devons nous différencier au delà de
notre savoir faire
mettons notre savoir être au service de
nos clients donnons leur envie de
travailler ensemble et durablement
j'ai juste envie de créer des emplois et
aussi l'embauché des apprentis
je n'ai pas fait d'études pour devenir
dirigeant je n'ai pas non plus les
compétences techniques
conscient de mon manque d'expérience je
m'attends à ce que la mission soit
compliqué à devoir travailler énormément
je sais que je ferai des erreurs et
qu'elles ne serviront à progresser je
suis déterminé
j'ai pas d'autre moyen que de faire
confiance en mes collaborateurs je leur
fais faire des choix en les questionnant
je sais que leurs solutions techniques
seront les meilleurs les salariés me
font confiance je sens qu'ils croient en
moi je les valorise
comme mon père m'a valoriser je me
souviens de ce précieux cadeau et je le
remercie la confiance que je porte en et
collaborateurs a été une véritable allié
dans le développement de l'entreprise
à aucun moment pendant ces dix ans je
n'ai ressenti que nous étions en crise
j'ai bien vécu quelques années noires
mais rien à voir avec une quelconque
guerre aux crises économiques
j'apprenais tout simplement mon métier
de dirigeant avec mon équipe
expérimentée appliquée se tromper à
prendre réajuster grandir l'activité se
diversifier avec des projets sur des
bâtiments d'architectes de renom et des
emplois se créent 20 en dix ans cette
mission que mon père m'a confiées mener
à bien mon projet d'entrepreneurs créer
de la richesse pour mon pays et créer de
l'emploi
je l' ai accompli je suis aujourd'hui
entouré de 23 collaborateurs
je suis fier de cette équipe unie
dynamique sérieuse et engagé qui fait
vivre l'entreprise au quotidien
j'espère à présent que comme moi vous
avez cette conviction
la france est la terre de tous les
possibles
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]